so yesterday we talked about the g20
meeting in Germany and one of the big
products of Donald Trump's meeting with
Vladimir Putin was this harebrained idea
of the u.s. working with Russia on the
issue of cybersecurity which is
laughably preposterous given that we
need to protect ourselves from
cyberattacks from Russia I said
yesterday it's sort of like if you were
to hire the Foxes to partner with you on
a henhouse guardianship program or
something like that and it only took 12
hours for Donald Trump to bail on that
idea after Democrats and Republicans and
anybody with a brain said hey this is
kind of absurd both senators Republican
senators Lindsey Graham and John McCain
had really funny comments on it this
first one is from Meet the Press on
Sunday morning were Senator Lindsey
Graham commented on Trump's Russian
cybersecurity partnership idea well let
me start with Russia and the president
and the cybersecurity statement he put
out there he wants to work with Vladimir
Putin claiming that this cybersecurity
unit will prevent future election
hacking and many other negative things
will be guarded what say you sir it's
not the dumbest idea I've ever heard but
it's pretty close not the dumbest idea
I've ever heard but it's pretty close
and then Senator John McCain equally
funny on this issue the president
announced and the White House said this
is the significant achievement of their
meeting the president again tweeting
this morning said Putin and I discussed
for me an impenetrable cybersecurity
unit so that election hacking and many
other negative things will be guarded
what am i am sure that Vladimir Putin
could be of enormous assistance in that
effort since he's doing the hacking I
mean it's it's and so in the midst of
the blowback within just 12 hours Donald
Trump going to Twitter and backing off
of this absolutely ridiculous idea
saying quote the fact that President
Putin and I discussed the cybersecurity
unit doesn't mean I think it can happen
it can but a ceasefire can and did can
we say that a positive aspect of the
Trump era is
that the political timelines have been
massively accelerated and you can have a
ridiculous idea proposed destroyed by
criticism and retracted with in less
time than an average dog sleeps in a day
perhaps my favorite part of the story is
that in that interim between when the
cybersecurity commission was a good idea
and a bad idea
Treasury secretary Steve minuchin went
on ABC's this week and was talking about
oh yeah this is a great idea being
brought forward by the president and now
he just looks like an idiot he got
thrown under the bus because Trump
decided to repudiate him within hours
let's be honest though Pat Steve
minuchin looked like an idiot before
supporting the idea of a US Russia
cybersecurity partnership that's the
problem when blind loyalty is the most
important characteristic to this
president twelve hours and the idea is
dead in the water it was a pathetic idea
to begin with today's episode of the
David Pakman show is made possible in
part by Warby Parker eyeglasses Warby
Parker recently did the right thing and
ditched advertising on right-wing
conspiracy website Breitbart pulling
their ads off and you can get the free
five-day home Tryon from Warby Parker
check out their glasses I use them when
I'm not wearing contact lenses I started
with the free at-home trial they send
you five pairs of glasses you see which
ones you like you send them back and
whichever one you pick they will put
your prescription in - I like this
because I can actually show the glasses
to other people and not have to just
decide on the spot like in an eyeglass
store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
cost that including lenses and for every
pair sold they give a pair to someone in
need so to try the five pairs and
support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS